A última hora de este viernes el
congreso del Salvador de mayoría
oficialista con 67 de los 84 diputados
votó a favor de una séptima prórroga del
estado de excepción un régimen que
recordemos comenzó en marzo pasado con
el incremento de los asesinatos
atribuidos a las pandillas Mara
Salvatrucha y barrio 18 en esta
oportunidad fue a solicitud de el
presidente nayib bukele que se
prorrogará y por ellos suministro de
seguridad y de Justicia Gustavo
Villatoro presentó los diferentes
argumentos uno de ellos captar la
necesidad de los millones de
salvadoreños Quienes no quieren regresar
a un país con 600 homicidios al mes y
para ello destacó la cifra de que
durante la administración de nayib
bukele Van 215 días con cero homicidios
además se han capturado más de 55.000
pandilleros de los 75.000 que se tiene
registro 1644 armas incautadas 1,24
millones de dólares incautados
paralelamente organi de Derechos Humanos
como la organización cristosal han
denunciado más de 6000 casos de
presuntas irregularidades personas que
habrían sido capturadas completamente
inocentes sin relación con las pandillas
y 80 fallecidos en custodia de la
policía con todo y esto el presidente
nayib bukele es el mandatario
latinoamericano con la más alta
popularidad de 85% y luego de tres años
y cuatro meses en el poder y habiendo
dicho que se va a lanzar a una
reelección inmediata estaría asegurando
su segundo término en la presidencia que
por cierto está completamente prohibido
por varios artículos de la constitución